% c'est pas un éche et certains ne se
privverent pas de nous le reprocher mais
euh non vous savez on passe parfois des
heures à commenter des sondages qui ont
été réalisés sur 500 ou sur 1000
personnes là en l'occurrence on a
quasiment 80000 parisiens qui se sont
mobilisés pour ce vote et donc ça crée
une légitimité claire pour présenter une
délibération au mois de mai sur le sujet
qui pourra tripler le prix des SUV et et
de ce point de vue moi je me félicite de
cet exercice démocratique euh et par
ailleurs le le le résultat est
intéressant ça montre qu'il y a une
majorité à Paris pour considérer que la
priorité à l'environnement à la
réduction de la place des voitures
polluantes cette majorité elle est là
elle est claire et d'ailleurs elle fait
suite à à à à à des positions que les
Parisiens ont toujours défendu sur la
piétonnisation des voies sur Berg sur le
développement des pistes cyclables les
Parisiens sont majoréement là en
l'occurrence ils étaient interrogés sur
une mesure qui les concerne pas puisque
cette mesure elle ne concerne pas les
résident Parisien ce n'est pas vrai
parce que si vous êtes résident parisien
et que vous habitez par exemple le 16e
arrondissement vous aurez un tarif qui
augmentera si vous allez dans un autre
quartier que le vôtre donc au final si
les
parisiture fait mais enfin au final les
paris est-ce que du coup il ne faut pas
aller plus loin et interdire tous les
SUV dans la capitale cette question
viendra peut-être aujourd'hui nous
n'aurions pas au vu de la loi le droit
d'interdire totalement l'accès ou la
possession d'un SUV à Paris ça ça ça ne
serait pas légal non mais en tout cas de
tripler le stationnement pour tout le
monde en tout cas nous allons au maximum
de ce que la loi nous permet de de de de
faire et je le redis quand on est Paris
par que la loi vous aura empêché de
taxer le stationnement résiden quand on
est parisien et qu'on habite le 16e on
n'est pas tout le temps en bas de chez
soi il arrive quand même que justement
on prenne sa voiture et qu'on aille dans
d'autres quartiers de Paris et à ce
moment-là on sera effectivement soumis à
cette augmentation du du tarif de
stationnement est-ce que qu'est-ce que
vous dites aux familles qui viennent à
Paris dans des monospaces qui aussi du
coup sont concernés qui viennent de
banlieu qui viennent de province ell
pouront plus à Paris non mais je je je
je leur dis ce que les Parisiens ont
majoritairement dit hier par leur votes
ce sont des voitures qui sont polluantes
qui sont encombrantes et donc vous avez
tout à fait le droit de les utiliser
mais ce tarif FAM mais mais ce tarif
sera plus important vous savez toutes
les études montrre que ceux qui
utilisent à Paris des SUV sont la
plupart du temps seuls donc je veux bien
que certains nous explique que ce sont
des voitures populaires que ce sont des
voitures familiales je le redis la
grande majorité de ceux qui les utilise
à Paris sont des hommes seuls et donc en
l'occurrence ça n'a rien à faire avec la
défense de la
famille